uh my name is max arshinov and for
my day job i'm a cto at ita group
which is an outsourcing company based in
kazan russia
our main focus is building custom
complex systems for
our clients and for the past three years
i have been speaking at various
conference
conferences though that's my first time
at ndc
and i'm very happy to be a part of it
and for
the past two years i also have been
teaching in kazan university so this is
some background information about me
unfortunately i don't have a twitter
account but you can find me on facebook
or email me
so we live in a strange time normally i
expect that
the audience to share the same room with
the speaker
however this is impossible now so i
tried to take advantage of this new
format
my talk includes some live coding please
feel free to clone the repository
if it's more convenient to you to have
the code open on your second screen
in your favorite ide you can also find
the presentation and the links and
everything that i mentioned during the
talk
uh by this link so and the last thing
before we begin
please text me on in slack or
in webex chat if there's any
uh where you are now hopefully this
knowledge can help us to feel
connected to each other some feedback
for instance i'm at my office right now
in kazan
despite that about 1.5 million people
live
in the city i don't expect that
foreigners uh
know any russian cities apart from
moscow and maybe
petersburg so here's the clue i'm only
eight
22 kilos to the east from moscow and
when i say
only i mean it here in russia we really
consider this a short distance
anyway let's get started so today i'm
gonna be talking about expression trees
if you had asked me a few years ago if i
wanted to know the implementation
details of this technology i would have
100 sure answered no because
then i thought that expression trees are
just part of link
so i didn't expect that there might be
some other way to apply them in real
life scenarios
apart from maybe feeding them into like
wearable extension methods
such as select wear and order by
everything started with just one short
refactoring or
more precisely with something that i
thought would be a short refactoring
in reality it was a starting point down
the rabbit hole
again the experience on how to properly
use expression trees over several years
after this incident
we only have about an hour uh so i'm not
going to tell you
uh the chronology i will only present
you a fact
uh i only present you facts and uh
i will ignore the chronological order so
let's just pretend that you are a
random person who just have got a new
job
as a developer for the commerce solution
i will use this example because
e-commerce domain is well known
so i hope that business rules will be
straightforward to everyone
every business system has some business
rules involved so let's start with a
simple one
our manager asked us to show on the ui
only those products
for which is for sale checkbox is
selected
in the admin area all
other products should be considered as
drafts and should not be shown to
customers
no problem we can easily write code like
this so far
so good after a while the manager is
changing her mind
his for sale rule still applies but now
she wants to remove products
that are not in stock from the ui
because customers kind of get upset when
they
are told that their products are
unavailable after payment and not before
it
so this should be an easy fix let's
introduce another property and call it
in stock
and get another one just to combine both
condition into a single
read-only property so so that
we can encapsulate the filtering rules
in a convenient way
well and uh has anyone already guessed
what i'm getting at right now
if so please let me know in the chat
let's check okay the link is works
perfect
link is working well the problem is that
this code compiles and perfectly
works with in-memory variables but it
fails in runtime when working with a
real db
unless you have other uh i've written
some default rm behavior
the problem is that the is available
property is not mapped to any table
column so
orm doesn't really know which column
should be included in
the select statement of the sql query
an easy fix would be to add
the to list call just before the work
hold but this is not acceptable solution
in many cases
we really cannot assume that there are
just a few products in the database
there might be thousands of millions on
them
so querying them all into memory is not
an option
okay there is another simple fix
let's get rid of the is available
property and just copy paste the
condition as is
this is definitely an easy solution but
what will you do
when you have hundreds of lines like
this maintenance of such a code base
might be a nightmare
and we all know that repeating yourself
is not a god
not a good thing right so
in order to come up with a better
solution we need to examine
the basics from the very beginning why
the same lambda
perfectly works when it's applied to an
in-memory database and fails with a real
one
have you ever tried to define a lambda
function using a var statement
you can't do this because it just won't
compile
the c-sharp compiler will ask you to be
more specific about
whether you would like to define a
delegate or an expression
so even these two lambdas look the same
they have different type so basically
these
are different things in terms of the
programming language
however it's not difficult to transform
an expression into a delegate
let's say we have a simple expression
like this
to get the corresponding delegate
we only need to call the compile method
which will kindly unwrap the expression
and provide you with the instance of the
underlying function
the only disadvantage of this approach
is that this is a compilation process
which is a synonym with a relatively
slow process
performance considerations might be
important for your project or not
but anyway generally speaking none of us
want random compilations to happen in
the app we develop and maintain
so is there a chance that there is an
inverse transformation
that is faster than the compilation
process the answer is kind of
yes and no at the same time
the solution is proposed by another
russian developer his name is alexander
zaitsev
his approach is the following let's
decorate
the is available property with a special
attribute
and add a special decompile method
the implementation of the decompile
method is quite tricky
it uses the git get il as a byte array
method
available as a part of method input type
which is a part of system.reflection
namespace
this method behaves exactly as you might
expect it returns backery of the il
instructions
under the hood these bytes are
translated into objects using
mono reflection once we have those
objects we can translate them into
expression trees
the decompile method searches for
properties marked with
computed attribute and replaces the
original call
of the is available property with its
body
this is kind of run time hand written in
lining mechanism
for expressions although
this process is completely unintuitive
this approach might be better in terms
of performance in many cases
the bad thing is that delegate the
compiler nuget package
has stuck on version 0.28 and
it's not supported
so practically speaking starting from
expression and transforming them into
delegates all the way seems to be
a much more reliable solution provided
though that performance limitations are
not a problem for a project
or there is a way to solve them during
this talk i will only consider the
approach when delegates are created from
expressions
and expressions are never created from
delegates i'll be using cash to reduce
the performance impact
we are good to go up here let's review
another use case
some criteria don't have to always be
used together
we might want to show products that are
for sale or
are in stock in different contexts
independently
and sometimes we might want to only show
the products that satisfy both criteria
so there is an easy way to do it when a
predicate is combined using the
and statement we can just chain multiple
work calls together and let query
provider do the job
also corresponding lambdas can be easily
defined as static read-only variables
so we don't have to bother with possible
code duplications
but what if i wanted to combine some
criteria using the
or operator
i need something like this and here's
the problem
this code won't compile once again
because the or operator is not defined
for the expression found bull type
this scenario is addressed within the
scope of the specification button
this pattern is explained in the main
drawing design blog book
by eric evans and is frequently used in
the context of domain driven design
so let's take a closer look
the pattern outlines a business rule
that is combinable with
other business rules in this example
that we now see on the screen a unit of
business logic inherits its
functionality from the abstract
composite specification class
the composite specification class has a
one function called
is satisfied by that returns a boolean
value this is kind of authentic
implementation from java world
the usage of this implementation is
quite limited because it relies on the
is satisfied by method which assumes
that all the data is available in memory
you surely can try to overcome this
problem by combining specifications with
query object button
however you will most likely end up
finding yourself sinking into quicksand
parsing all available combinations of
your specification with
which essentially means implementing a
mechanism very similar to expression
trees on your own
luckily we don't have to do this because
microsoft has already gave us the
technology
so we only need to build a tiny wrapper
on top of the original expression
function type and add
boolean support so this code will compel
will compile it's not only solved
the original problem but also improved
the readability and reusability of our
code
which is nice so let's
take a closer a closer look at the
implementation
here is how the operators are defined in
the wrapper
there is just one little thing to do
unfortunately these matters just don't
exist
but we can fix that by writing some
extension methods so
let's write some code
and now we are at the point when you can
open your favorite ide if you like
i'll be sharing my screen and talk and
talk you through the code
so you can follow me here or using your
setup either approach works for me
so the naive implementation
would look like this i started with this
one so
here's the expression here's the another
one
and expression dot or
else looks like a good starting point
and
yeah maybe maybe
maybe this would work i don't know so
that was uh my thoughts actually
what we what we have here
this implementation will fail with
invalid operation exception
let's check that
so you see this on the screen
okay let's check another implementation
so the problem was that i was trying to
combine
combine lambdax expressions
so love essentially is a body
and parameters so
argument exception is trying to tell us
that
just makes no sense to combine two
lambdas together
instead of trying to combine lambda
let's try
to combine lambda's bodies
and this is this is something
which is closer to the actual
implementation but
still fails but with another exception
which is system argument exception
and trust me let's verify that
and the exception would be incorrect
number of parameters supplied for lambda
declaration
so now you can trust me
well
that was uh kind of disappointing
because
you cannot easily find the official
documentation
how to do this properly so instead of
[Music]
instead of following the official
documentation i had to
search on the internet looking for
answers
and luckily i found one
joseph alba is famous for being the
author of
c sharp in a nutshell book
and he is also the author
of linkipad software and linkyukit
library
that uses link you keep internally
joseph needed to solve the same issue
for the linker kit so he suggested using
using expression invoke to fix the issue
and this approach works for me
at least partially the combined
expression
works as expected when applied to
in-memory variables
or when compiled into delegate it also
works fine with entity framework core
but not with entity framework 6
and entity framework 6 will throw not
supported exception
once you try to pass this the expression
that combines at least
one instance of expression invoke in
the expression tree so
why that's a good question
let's review the explain uh let's
let's first examine the official
documentation
here's what i found um in the official
i think that you have already read this
from the screen
so does it make sense to you
no okay here is the explanation
from jodoff
any better now
actually it doesn't matter because the
original goal
was to be able to combine the
expressions as if you wrote the
uh wrote them uh by hand
so joseph recommends fixing this problem
using a special as expandable method
and i won't go to the technical details
of this method here
that's too tedious and boring uh
furthermore there is another method for
achieving the
same result which creates exactly the
same expression tree
as if wrote by hand i borrowed this
implementation from the
from the blog post by pete montgomery
who in turn claims that
it was meek ef team who introduced
that technique to him
so let's get back to food
so first let's examine
the implementation
of joseph albachar
so let's take a look that's the first
expression
which is x less than one or else
x greater than three and
the another one
i'm not sure if you can see the text
here um
let me try to all right
so oh
okay so here is invoke which
would never happen here if we build this
expression
by hand and um
here is the
original expressions so there is no
there is no invoke here
what pitman montgomery suggests
to do is a little bit trickier
what we need here is a way to compose
expressions with parameters and the
exception was due to the parameters was
binded to
the body of the previous expressions
expression in what we need
we need to rebind all the parameters
uh from one one expression to another
so here is the tricky part we take first
expression
we take the second expression and we
take the function
that will merge those expressions in our
case that's
or else expression we create a
dictionary
to map all the parameters and
now for the second body we replace
all the parameters with the parameters
of the first expression uh which
parameter rebinder replace parameter
method will do for us
and once those parameters are rebinded
from expression one to expression two
we can create uh lambdas
which uh would look like exactly
if as we wrote them by hand
and let's check this as well so
here was um implementation by the file
bahari
so let's check this
so this works which means that these two
implementation
this one and another one
that's my previous debug session
so these two
will be exactly the same the same
this technique not only makes it
possible to combine predicates with
or and not statements but also unlocks
some more advanced tricks let's say we
have a specification for a product
and we have a specification for a
category
or a product group if you will so we
would like to sort all the categories
and
put ones that have a good enough rating
on top
what i what if i need to reuse the
specification that is originally defined
for the category class
for products still
i cannot do this again because of
the type mismatch unless i call select
many instead of select
but what if i don't want to what if i'm
under certain circumstances
when i only have a queryable product
what we have here
that takes category as an in and
produces boolean
value as a result
when the lambda that takes product as
input
and produces boolean as a result
so in order to use the existing
specification we only need another
expression that takes product
and returns category
once combined we've got exactly what we
need those of you
who are familiar with functional
programming might notice that this might
somehow remind you
what functional composition is for those
who are not familiar with
functional programming i highly
recommend watching power composition
talk by scott flashing
scott has already given this talk today
but i think that you can find
this video on youtube as well
so we are finally at the point when the
true power of
expression trees is revealed once we
figured out how to combine expressions
of any kind it's clear that this is a
powerful code generation tool which
still much easier to use than the things
like reflection emit
number two some expression might be
easily written compiled into delegates
and cached
and number three other ones can be
dynamically built in runtime and later
combined
or not with some expressions that are
written by human beings
that's meta programming time
so the first good example of using
expression
expressions accompanied by reflection is
automapper
so
let's take a look
so let's say we have products
and what we used to write
is a boring code with handwritten
selects
if i have a data a video and
i have almost the same um
properties in this detail i have to
write tedious and boring mapping code
uh the things like this are kind of
obvious if a detailer has
the category name property that it's
obvious that it should be mapped to a
category name a property of the original
entity
so this how product list dtl looks like
category name here and the original
entity
is
it's here so yeah that's obvious product
dot category dot name so instead of
instead of writing this boring code by
hand we can use automapper
project2 method which will kindly
build all of these mappings
uh automatically based on conventions
but what if i told you
that we can do the same trick with
filtering and
sorting basically that
is how system link dynamic core works
under the hood
so let me run the web up
so let's see here is my
very simple minimalistic e-commerce
solution
and i have some laptops here some
smartphones
what if i'm interested in apple
macbooks only here that's fine
okay what if i would like to find
something else that's fine
filtering is working
also maybe i would like to sort by
name or sometimes i'd like to sort by
price
the sorting also works so you might be
thinking that
there is a boring code like e filter is
said then
add where statement blah blah blah no
it works like this
so let me remove this commanding code
for now
i have a product filter plus
a simple one that has name and price
and my product class also has name
and price property
so
this means that if product filter
name property is set or price
product filter dot price property is set
we can build this filter automatically
and that's what i do
so i need to write uh just one liner
here and spec builder
is a is a helper
helper class that we commonly use in our
production code
uh so it automatically searches for the
same properties by conventions
then caches the filter query and
uh i have
overridden uh the implicit operator
operator for
and this specification that is built by
spec builder so
i can i can use
the specification instance as a
parameter to wear a method
so no more boring filtering code the
same
stuff for ordering this is
a little bit tricky because order by
method is not the only one we have order
by an order by descending
and we have two generics there
so the implementation is a little bit
more difficult
i'll just show you sources to give you
a general idea but i wouldn't go into
technical details
because well it's more like writing
some boring code once in order to avoid
writing boring code all the time
so let's get back to the presentation
actually that was that was a simple one
we can do some crazy things for instance
data validation is a very common task
that can be simplified
long time ago um when
we were younger and there was no react
angular view and dozens of other
javascript frameworks
we used write validation logic once on
the back end
and welcome to brand new world no one
uses server site rendering anymore
web is spi sent me now so now we have to
write validation
logic twice one on the back end and the
other one on the front end
but we didn't have to javascript
developers use
babel to transpile javascript code to
another javascript code
or g6 to javascript or typescript to
javascript
anything to javascript i have a better
idea
what if we just generated it from
g-sharp
instead of writing it so luckily there
are libraries
javascript libraries to build web forms
with
built-in validation support so let's try
try to take advantage of
it here here are some examples
this is a screenshot from tcop tcomp
form
project on github take a look at
var predicate
predicate equals function which returns
x
uh greater or equals zero
looks like an expression right
then this is ngx formally a form builder
for angular
and what we see here validators
ip well these are
expressions we only need to build
exactly the same expressions
from the c-sharp code and transfer them
somehow to
the front-end we can even include this
method mate information into this work
definitions if we want to make sure that
some essential information is
communicated to the front-end as a part
of type definitions
and let's get back to the code now
so
[Music]
i'll open my
example which is t-com
um okay let's go here and
i'll click on save and now i see that
price must be
greater than 100
so um
when i when i click here
what you might not have seen is that
that there is a
server request which gets the error
message and the predicate from the
server
so let's get back here
what i do here is when component then
multi-mod function is called
and that's the best way to do web
request
in react we do
a adjective request to api
form method of our controller and uh
get the json file then we build this
refi
uh refinement from data that is
transferred from the backend
and this data is
c-sharp expression that i translated to
well in this particular example to
string
but we can also translate it to
perfectly valid javascript and in this
specific example
in this specific case uh string actually
works for us
because what we get is
a valid javascript the translation would
be exactly the same
so i borrowed this implementation from
from the existing expression dot to
string method
which is basically an expression visitor
it's quite complicated to to
transpile all kinds of c sharp code to
all kinds of javascript code and i don't
think that
that's even possible because uh these
are just
different languages and they're
basically two different so there are
subsets of code that cannot be
translated to javascript
but what we can do we can create
a reasonable subset of the expressions
that we would like to support in our
application
and then for instance we can define
we can define a validation attribute
and decorate our code with this kind of
validation attribute
that will include validation logic
which is defined as expressions from
our type to boo then these expressions
can be transferred to javascript and
we don't have to write any javascript
validation on our own
because this javascript will be
generated for us
all right
so what about tests
i i've got some more weird scenarios
where expression trees might be helpful
you might be familiar with mocking
frameworks like mocu
what you might not notice is that how
mocu builds mocks
internally now you're looking at
screenshot from the
marquee documentation these lines of
code are not delegates
these are expressions so moku actually
analyzes the expressions
uh the expression trees i'm sorry and
uses castle.dynamic proxy internally to
compile classes in runtime
so the code that you write in the setup
will never run
an expression visitor will walk through
the tree and create a class
that is actually will be created so this
is a tree that's not
coded being invoked
i realized that this trick might be
abused even harder
i don't have a live demo for that but
just let me know if you
want to go to some uh technical details
what we can do is to build a method
that takes any controller from our
solution
and which takes a controller method
as a parameter provided that this
parameter
is an expression and not delegate so by
um by passing this
um expression into some special function
we can analyze the invocation of the
controller method at ins
and instead of instantiating the
original controller
uh we can build a web request so that's
how we can
um write uh integration tests
that actually uh do web requests to out
to our api but
we can use our our source code
including detail files including
controllers including
intellisense so
we would write a code that looks like a
call
of uh a method of the controller but
what would actually happen is that we
we would provide a an expression tree to
the method
then this method will be analyzed and
once
it's analyzed we build a
web request and this web request goes to
the server
and get back and everything is being
analyzed under the hood
so this idea somehow is related to
computation expressions uh in f-sharp
if you if you know what i mean so
anyway this is a complex topic so if you
have some
additional questions please let me know
and just ask me
and we can discuss the details
last but not least this is a topic that
we
actively discussed with vagifa belov
you might know him as a musician and
in the seaspeaker we together with him
and with dylan beatty and some other
great guys they're from geeks at
conferences from time to time
and time to time and i hope that we
could have done a great gig here at
andes this year
well you know maybe next time
so i'm feeling lucky about it uh
anyway vagine told me that um
he has been under impression that rule
engine that comes with
microsoft wins workflow foundation is
slow
very slow so um he and his team
used to i used it to execute some of
their business rules
and uh soon they found out that rule
processing
slows down the entire application
execution that was
really strange it was hard to believe
that
industry strength through engine like
this needs a long time to process that
because these business rules were
quite simple so
eventually they ran a profiler and it
immediately showed that there that
the time was spent in
just one place in fact it was not the
actual rule validation but preparation
for it
in sensation of the wf rule passer
the parser class is not public so they
used
a trick to obtain its instance
they retrieved its non-public
constructor information with a
reflection
and then called invoke and it was so
slow that they
noticed it even in their integration
tests
so what they did is they choose their
constructor information
compiled expression and location to
into their bits cached them and
used them instead of activate or create
instance you can see some benchmarks
here
so activator and
constructor invoke and the difference
is uh huge when we use
uh constructor
so here's the clue
you can use uh compiled expression
instead of
reflection of course i don't really mean
somebody should completely stop using
activator create instance but
there are certain use cases like iec
frameworks
when it gives clear performance
advantage so let's review the
iec framework performance comparison
table
clearly some of them are faster than
other
is it coincident i don't think so
and i just know because i examined the
implementation of
single injector that under the hood what
they do they
build the composition route they search
for all the dependencies
then they create the constructors
compile them and
and that's all once compiled uh we
run delegates no reflection invoked
no not not record no not reflect later
reflection and location i'm sorry so
basically
don't use invoke either
um wrapping up so
what we learn uh after three years of
actively using expression trees in real
projects
your team can deliver crude much faster
and write less code
in.net javascript typecrip and probably
any other languages then
your lead developer has to know some
advanced stuff
number three expression.compile can be
cached
if all expressions are defined as static
and that's why you want to define
all or most of your expressions as
static
so your your code might be shorter
but harder to understand and that's a
trade-off you need to decide if you want
to go into some
uh technical details some weird stuff
if you can get advantage of it
and that's pretty much
this is it so